Speaker 1: All right, everybody. It's mailbag
time, it is that time of the week where I look
through the mailbag we are now getting.
Man, what are what are we up to? We get
about a thousand emails a week now. I would say,
like actual emails. You know, some people say
total number of comments. We get like four to 5000
comments a day. If you include tweets, Facebook
comments, Instagram comments, Instagram messages,
YouTube comments, e-mail everything together.
Email someone actually taking time to email
info at David Pakman dot com. It's about a
thousand a week, and I want to highlight
some different things for you here today,
all relevant in some way. As a reminder, if you
are new to this program, new to our environment,
one of the things that I have just accepted
as part of doing this as as my my thing is
really horrible. People write to me
and Bill, for example, wrote to me
and said, Show my email on your YouTube page,
you f-ing Jew F. And then that second f is the,
you know, the pejorative for a gay person. This
is every day, so every day of the 5000. 100 to 150
are this type of thing, this is the world we live
in, we can't just say, Hey, you know what? David,
I disagree with you about how taxes should
be organized. No, it's you F-ing Jew F. This
does not bode well for society. This is not
making me think we're very close to achieving
some greater level of understanding and problem
solving by working to get now. It doesn't seem
that that's the way it's going to go. Next email
who pays you? I sort of love this question in a
way because, you know, sometimes this question is
overtly antisemitic. Like what? Take your Soros
Jew money and stop pushing communism, you know,
whatever. But it's actually I love the way that
we're organized, which is our number one funding
source is people in our audience. It's just
people, people who ask the question, it's people
like you, not you, but people like you that pay us
through our membership program. And yeah, you
know, we're part of YouTube's monetization
program, Facebook's when they allow us. We've got
some advertisers, et cetera. But basically, we're
viewer funded. And that's a great thing because
there's no one person that can say, David, unless
you do or say, we're going to pull your funding.
If one member comes to me as they sometimes do
and recently did, which we'll get to in a moment
and says David, unless you take exposition,
I'm pulling my funding well, pull your two bucks
a month, pull your $60 a year or whatever. Nobody
has this under their thumb because so many
different people fund us. So that's who pays us,
and it's a really, really great thing. OK,
a lot of controversy, surprisingly, I guess,
over the pronunciation of the capital of Ukraine.
One such person wrote to me and said, David,
it's pronounced Kiev. And then a couple of hours
later, they wrote back and full respect to them.
They said, My apologies. I just checked it. You're
right. The back story on this and the reason why
we now say Kiev and spell it k why ivy is that
much like in LA, what's a good example? This isn't
a perfect example, but you guys know how the name
Wynberg in English. Sometimes you see it spelled
WDI, and sometimes it's WIC. Sometimes it's W h
i. And at the end of the burg part, sometimes it's
B.R. G. Sometimes it's b u r y y. Is that well,
it's being. It's being translated from languages,
Hebrew, Yiddish, which don't always put the vowels
in. So it really it's the root, it's the the W
and WNBA G and the vowels sort of don't matter.
So there's different ways you can do it. And
similarly, when it comes to Kiev, for a while,
it was a more anglicized spelling Kyiv. And when
people looked at Kiev, logically, they said that's
Kiev. It was eventually updated, an NPR and other
media outlets announced. When they were doing
this, they said, You know, really, the more proper
spelling would be k y IV in translating from
the Cyrillic. And as a result, we're also going
to be calling it Kiev, which is more in line
with the actual Ukrainian pronunciation. So
this is actually this this is a years old story
because of what's going on in Russia, Ukraine now,
more people are talking about it and gladly
so. All right. I told you there are people
pulling financial support and looking to hurt
us very badly. And a lot of those people,
like Tulsi Gabbard, we actually do have a
fraction of our audience that likes Tulsi,
and they don't like that. Last week, I said. Tulsi
is a confirmed scammer, grift or whatever. And
so one such person is Robert. Robert wrote to me
and said, Dear David, list is polite. Dear David,
I have unsubscribed from your show because you
reveal your are tribal, your are tribal, you look
for labels and you follow the liberal official
narrative. Tulsi Gabbard speaks to citizens of all
labels, calling us to remember our common ground
is far greater than our pet peeves. Be, well, wake
up. Robert Robert has canceled his membership.
That's right, Robert pulled his six bucks a month.
And so what I'm asking you is if you don't
like this kind of stuff, I would love for
you to sign up on our web. Join Packman dot com.
I think there's many more people in our audience
who support what we do and understand the
Tulsi scam. Then the people like Robert,
who are trying to hurt us financially for making
that assessment, Vincent wrote in. Vincent said,
Dear David, thank you for speaking the truth
about Tulsi Gabbard. She's been spreading lies
and Russian propaganda since the beginning,
and it's important to counter those lies. Keep
doing what you're doing best. Vincent, thank you,
Vincent. And I will tell you the vast majority of
the feedback to us saying, Guys, if you fell
for the Tulsi scam, it's over. Just say you
were wrong and say you're going to do better next
time you and you now have learned it was. Mistake,
but you learned and now you won't fall for
similar scams in the future. Overwhelmingly,
people reacting very positively to that very
positively. People saying things like what Vincent
says every once in a while, though, someone like
Robert canceling his membership comes through.
Next e-mail is from Cindy Cindy has an idea about
how to refer to Trump. She says, I have an idea I
would love to see it catch on. Maybe if you would,
it would if you would use it every time Donald
Trump refers to someone who opposes him or an
organization that opposes him. He loves to use the
word failed in front of their name or title, like
the failed New York Times, failed gubernatorial
candidate, whoever. What if, instead of referring
to him as former President Donald Trump,
we started referring to him as failed
presidential candidate Donald Trump? Truthful,
accurate and utterly triggering. Love what you
do. Keep it up. Yeah, I think I like this idea.
I'm going to make an effort, and sometimes it's
really hard to kind of use the lexicon that one
tends to use. I'm going to make an effort to say,
instead of former President Donald Trump, I'm
going to say failed President Donald Trump because
he did fail and he failed by his own standards.
It's not just my assessment from the left that
he failed the things he said he would do. He
never did. He said he would build a wall across
the entire US-Mexico border. He didn't do it.
He said he would fix trade. He didn't do it. He
said he would put out a beautiful replacement plan
for Obamacare that would be great for everybody.
Not only did he not get that done, he didn't even
tell us what the plan is or how it will work.
Remember, in August of twenty nineteen, it was
two weeks away, I think, from coming out. It never
did. By his own standards, by his own standards,
he is a failed president. So Cindy, I like
the way you're thinking. I'm going to try to
refer to Trump as failed President Donald Trump, a
bunch of people writing to me about my rant about
electric vehicles. Last week, someone emailed
or left a voicemail rather and said, David,
most electricity still comes from fossil fuels,
so our electric cars really better. I laid out
a ton of reasons why they are. But I missed some
reasons, and Rickard wrote in and said, David,
just listen to you. Explaining why electric
cars are better are the better environmental
choice compared to gas powered everything
you said is valid. I want to add another
argument which will make it much more tangible.
I used to own a Volvo V40 because I'm Swedish.
Makes sense. It's a small hatchback comparable to
a small sedan. It consumed roughly half a liter of
diesel per 10 kilometers, which translates to five
kilowatt hours. I now own a Tesla Model three,
and it consumes 1.6 to 2.3 kilowatt hours per
10 kilometers. In other words, the Tesla is much
more energy efficient. This means even if all the
electricity produced from powering electric cars
was produced by burning diesel, it's still
more efficient to use electric cars. And
I totally missed this, and this is a really
good point. We can say, Well, you go 100 miles
with gas burning gas or you go 100 miles using
electricity derived from burning coal. Either way,
it's fossil fuels. But the point here is the
efficiency of doing it through electricity
is significantly higher. Even accounting for the
heavier vehicles because the batteries are heavy,
that's a really, really good point from Rickard.
And then one more here. Similar idea from Mark
Mark wrote in and said David loved the segment
about switching to electric and renewables, but
you missed the big point. Even if 100 percent of
electricity was generated by burning fossil fuels,
the power plants are more than
four times as energy efficient
versus the gas powered engine in your car. Keep
up the good work. So a similar idea, which is if
you have all of the burning of gas happening in
100000 cars, that has one level of efficiency in
converting that fossil fuel to movement in the
vehicle if it's done centrally at a power plant
and then distribute it out via electricity.
It is more efficient in terms of how much
fossil fuel consumption there is for moving those
100000 cars some distance, 10 miles, 100 miles,
whatever the case may be. So I understated. I
understated the relative efficiencies of electric
vehicles in the segment last week. But so many
people in our audience very keyed into that and
loved the opportunity to say more about it. If
you have an email, you can email info at David
Pakman dot com. It may be selected. Remember, we
get about a thousand a week. We feature ten. So
those are those are the odds make of it what you
will. And we have a fantastic bonus show coming up
for you today. Sign up at Join Pack Incom.
Unidentified: We will see it at.